네 저희 빌사남의 이번에 공인
중개사를 채용하고 있습니다 저희 회사
같은 경우에는 젊은 사람들이 똘똘
뭉쳐 가지고 끊임없이 도전하는
회사입니다 빌사남의 장점을 좀
설명드리자면 첫 번째 수평적인
회사예요 저 같은 경우에도 모든
사람들한테 다 존댓말을 합니다 아무리
신입 직원이 와도 다 존댓말을 하고
존경을 합니다 보통은 중개 업체나
이런 영업집 같은 경우에는 반말을
하거나 무시하거나 심지어 욕하는
경우도 있는데 우리 빌사남 같은
경우에는 그런 경우는 없습니다 일만
하게 최적 돼 있고 중계 외에 다른
일을 절대 하진 않습니다 그리고 두
번째로 일을 잘 배울 수 있는
회사입니다 그래서 저희 체계적인 교육
시스템이 있고 중개사님의 많은 고층이
뭐냐면 일을 안 알려 줘요 왜냐면
일을 알려 주면 나가서 차릴 거라고
생각을 하니까 근데 우리 회사 같은
경우에는 회사를
차리더니 그나 뭐 일을 안 알려
주는거나 그런 건 전혀 없어요
세무도우미
일 수 있고 좀 전문가로 거듭날 수
있는 그런 회사라고 저는 생각을
합니다 세 번째로는 콘텐츠 제작팀이
있어서 의지만 있다라고 하면 모든 걸
다 지원할 수 있거든요 뭐 광고뿐만
아니라 콘텐츠 제작도 되게 많이
하려고 해요 처음 저도이 중개
법인으로 시작하긴 했지만 건축사
사무소도 설립하고 시공사도 설립하고
이번에 자산운용사도 설립할 정도로이
중개 업무에서 확장할 수 있는 영들이
되게 크다라고 생각합니다이 중개업뿐만
아니라 다른 부분에서 확장을 할
부분이 있다라고 하면 저는 적극적으로
지지할 생각도 있고 심지어 투자할
생각도 있습니다 일단 중개업으로
시작하긴 했지만 꿈을 펼칠 수 있는
어 그런 기회들을 좀 많이 제공할
생각이고 여러 도전들을 하는 걸 저는
적극 지지합니다 적극 추천하고 그렇게
하셨으면 좋겠습니다 우리나라이 중계
진짜 인식이 아직 너무 안 좋긴
하지만이 중개사에 대한 인식을 좀
되게 바꾸고 싶은 생각도 되게 큽니다
그래서 이런 거를 도전하고 있고
새로운 걸 도전하고 있고 어떻게 하면
더 전문가가 될 수 있는지 되게 고민
을 많이 하고이 길이 없다면 다른
길을 찾고요 길도 안 된다면 또 다른
길을 찾고 만약에 벽이 안 뚫리면
어떻게 해서는 뚫으려고 할 거고 정말
그렇게 노력하는 CEO 그래고 저는
생각을 합니다 그래서 같이 열심히
싸우고이 어깨를 바꾸실 분들이 좀
오셨으면 좋겠습니다 그리고 최근에 구
파트너라고 변호사들 얘기를 다룬 그런
콘텐츠가 많이 생겨났는데 근데 아직
우리나라에는 그런 중개사를 다룬 그런
콘텐츠가 많이 없거든요 근데 그런
것도 되게 만들어서 이런 중개사에
대한 인식을 되게 바꾸고 싶은게 제
큰 소망입니다 그래서 금 마무리를
하자면 영업 조직의 그런 단점들을
되게 보완해서 장점으로 살린 그런
회사이고요 보인 의지에 따라서 충분히
내 성과를 낼 수 있는 그런 회사고
그리고 가장 트렌디하고 세상의 변화를
되게 유심히 보는 회사기 때문에
여러분들이 생각하시는 새로운 사업이나
이런게 있다라고 하면 저는 적극적으로
지지하고 도와드릴 생각이 있습니다
우리 회사 와서 이런 꿈들을
키우셨으며
스타들이 많이 나왔으면 좋겠어요 그
제의 빌사남 제의 김윤수 같은 스타
같은 공인중개사 분들이 많이 나왔으면
좋겠습니다 그래서 그 꿈을 저희가
실현시켜 드릴 거고 어떻게든 성장할
수 있게 도와드릴 거니까 같이
성장하고 같이 뭔가 도전하고 같이
커갈 수 있는 사람들이 좀 오셨으면
좋겠고 과감하게 이력서 보내 주시면은
저희가 검토에서 한번 연락을 드리도록
하겠습니다